[Musique]
l'école est finie les vacances d'été
commencent les manies quoi sont invités
à remettre leurs tongs plusieurs
ateliers notamment le bar à jus avec la
possibilité de faire un smoothie sur un
vélo pédaler pour se régaler verdict
après dégustation avec mathis 6 ans j'ai
fait du vélo avec un seau mousse pour
faire du souci était bouillant et les
soumet aussi c'était plus mes enfants
les adorent parce qu'il ya plein
d'animations la mobilité alternative est
aussi à l'honneur
balades en poney pour le côté
traditionnel un moyen de transport plus
futuriste avec l'initiation à
l'hoverboard tenir les équilibres avancé
et slalomer des moments passés entre les
parents et les enfants en famille alors
je trouve ses amis aussi
la l'école est terminée donc voilà c'est
ses copines lui manquait déjà donc à
leur profite
l'événement est très sympa en fait c'est
très familial en peut venir avec plein
d'enfants de tout âge magny les hameaux
organise pour la huitième fois cette
manifestation en collaboration avec une
dizaine d'associations de la commune cet
événement est mis en place pour
permettre aux jeunes maniwaki ont pas
forcément là l'occasion de partir en
vacance de pouvoir s'amuser
le temps d'une semaine autour de plein
d'activités on a des activités pour
toutes les catégories d'âge des murs
d'escaladé un airbag jump avec
possibilité de faire des figures en bmx
ou encore le pique nique du 14 juillet
sont prévus pour le reste de la semaine
près de 2000 personnes sont attendues
pour cette édition
[Musique]